We're back with the hosts of "The Good Dish",
Daphne Oz, Gail Simmons, and Jamika Pessoa.
And we're about to dig
into this delicious croissant bacon egg and cheese bake.
But first, how are you guys feeling about the show launch?
Like how's the vibes?
Oh wow.
The vibe's amazing.
We get to go to work with our friends every day,
first of all.
Mm-hmm.
We get to eat amazing food and experiment in the kitchen,
which I think has been so much fun.
And we get to teach and learn all at the same time.
I mean, we're two weeks in.
Learn from each other,
Teach the audience like it is just,
we give and take and they give it back to us
because with social media,
the audience can tell us what they want to see,
so we can create things like the dishes.
And it's like, we really connect with our audience,
which is so amazing.
We're definitely here to share some of our chef wisdom,
but it's more than that.
It's like what actually works.
What really gets dinner on the table at night?
What makes us feel good when we get in there,
and makes us feel positive
about like this one area
(audience applauding)
that we're going just to have a good time.
If I'm any indication of your viewers,
I was just so excited
that you're putting this show out there right now.
It's what I need.
And I'm so glad that you guys are here
and that we actually get to be together.
I am so happy!
Yes! Everyday,
Just pop over if you need something to eat.
We'll always feed you.
Full meal, T-bone steak, we'll hang.
We'll just, you know. Bring out the Merlot.
We got it all over in our studio, everything.
What do you think?
I love the bake.
W-w-what?
It's soft.
Mm-hmm.
Pillowy?
Pillowy.
Oh my gosh you guys, this is incredible.
Thank you so much for bringing this here today.
(audience applauding)
This is such a wonderful dish.
And this is just a preview
of what they'll get on "The Good Dish".
We cover everything and amazing guests like yourself.
I mean, we have cook-offs, we have beauty segments.
We're talking fashion.
It is everything that you need in an hour. Everything.
All the delicious things.
(audience applauding)
And really truly, we can't thank you enough
for just making us feel so welcome.
Yeah.
We love it so much.
Well, I was so excited to bring you guys
a little casserole, Gail, did you?
I did! We brought you something.
Oh my gosh.
Ooh, what could it be?
It's heavy and it's melting,
but that'll make it more delicious.
Because you need a good dessert after lunch.
(audience applauding)
Oh yeah, come on.
All right. That is from our brownie shell.
I mean, from our waffle shell, we put 99 things in a waffle.
Brownie waffles ice cream sandwiches you turn them into,
it's like that kind of stuff will blow your mind.
If there's anything happier and more infectious
than a show with you three ladies, I don't know what it is.
So thank you so much for coming.
Thank you.
Daphne, Gail and Jamika, "The Good Dish"
airs weekdays nationwide.
(audience applauding)
Check your local listings.
Thank you so much you guys
for choosing to spend your time with us.
We make this show for you, so take it with you!
(cheerful music)